Hi, my name is Shimon.
Today, I'll talk about a personal AI
system that knows you, but won't do
anything instead of you or on your
behalf,
and won't blow up your life.
So, that's good.
In the process, I'll talk about the
risks of personal AI and how read-only
AI systems like this one mitigate them.
Let's get started.
The whole personal AI space is obsessed
with agents that act on your behalf.
I built something different.
The starting point, six sources, read
access only, no write permissions. The
limitation is fully intentional.
But first of all, what are cognitive
exhaust fumes? What are they?
It's my term for the digital activity
that is a byproduct of your cognition.
Like exhaust fumes for a car engine,
individually, it's just waste, but if
you analyze the exhaust, you can
diagnose the engine.
So, let's see some examples of what the
exhaust reveals.
What does this enable you to do?
Three top uses I've found,
intention action gaps,
attention drift,
and relationship decay.
No single source tells you any of this,
and the cross-source
ability is what these have in common.
Your email client doesn't know what you
journaled. Your task manager doesn't
know what you're browsing. The
cross-source signal is the product.
Let's take a closer look at the system.
Here it is, Fulan. Three zones. The
sources are read-only. The AI never
writes back to them.
The workspace is where the analysis
happens. The outputs land in a separate
Obsidian vault for me to review, but it
doesn't have to be a separate Obsidian
vault. It could be separate Notion,
separate text files, separate anything.
Could be any other system.
And that's the whole thing.
So, what about applications?
Let's start with a David Allen style
getting things done like spin on the
weekly reflection.
Based on the six sources, the AI
synthesizes an occasionally brutal
reflection on how you spent your week.
Let's look at a real example.
Everything runs in Claude. I've stored
this
logic in the weekly reflection \
command \ skill.
And what it does is it launches a Python
script that gets
all the data
that come from the read-only sources,
and looks through them, and creates
structured outputs
with specified prompts that I've
prepared.
This takes a little bit of a while. It
pings the Anthropic API
to get those structured outputs back.
And [snorts] once it does, it will
create a markdown document that I will
be able to review.
This is now uh finished running, so it
gives me an overview,
and I can open it back up in Cursor,
and I'll convert it to a preview that's
more readable,
and see that in fact, it does hit the
themes of the week.
It does hit some of the tensions and
conflicts that I need to think about.
Talks about my commitments and
relationships, which is mostly notable
by its omissions, and highlights the
notable moments as well as reflection
questions that I like to think about.
In short, this is not a productivity
report. It's a reflection on how you're
thinking, assembled entirely from
exhaust.
Let's take another example.
I like to discuss what I'm reading with
others, but sometimes I think I
shouldn't keep messaging the same three
people about it. So, I asked the AI,
"Given my recent reading, who in my
network should I be discussing this
with?"
This is the cross-source magic.
Four data sources, none of which were
designed to talk to each other, combined
into an insight you'd never get from any
single tool.
And all read-only.
Nothing was sent. Nothing was scheduled.
Just a suggestion for me to act on if I
choose.
Let me once again show you the demo.
Once again, this is a Claude skill,
>> [sighs]
>> but in this case, I've hidden
most of the guts of the Claude skill
into the cross-origin query, and ask for
the specific question uh
in plain language.
The plain language knows that it will
auto
that it will
activate
the specific skill for the cross-source
queries, and it now goes through the
databases that I've curated that I have
regular interest for, looks through the
Vivaldi SQLite database for the articles
that I've been reading the most,
and
after a while, it will figure out which
of these articles um are most read,
still open on tabs,
and which people might be curious about
it based on the profile. Now, this is
probably the weakest part. The Clay MCP
takes forever to run,
but it searches my CRM,
or my friend relationship system, I
suppose, so FRM,
for people who might be interested in
articles of on these topics.
Um
In this case, it's people interested in
AI, or people in European tech, or
people in education, which
coincidentally are three things that I
also am.
Now,
as you might notice, this takes up a lot
of tokens in the context window, so you
probably don't want to do this in a
session that is not clean, but it's not
a problem if it messes up a little bit
of the 1 million context window for 4.6,
and then you clear it again.
So, at this point, it's getting
the responses from all of the Clay
searches.
It synthesizes the people that I should
talk to,
and it maps them to one article each.
That's what the or it's about to map
them to one article each.
Uh
this requires a little bit of
uh
bash sorcery on behalf of Claude code,
but if you're running it with auto to
auto mode, or dangerous disk
permissions, you can get rid of that as
well.
And indeed, when I take a look at the
first results,
those look like the people that I might
want to talk to that I haven't talked to
yet about the kinds of articles that
I've been reading. So, thank you,
Claude.
Right, in this case, it even found the
author of the article that I was reading
that's in my network, so I should give
them a whirl.
In short, no source knows the whole of
this. Your browser doesn't know your
contacts. Your CRM doesn't know what
you're reading.
The exhaust does.
So, why keep it read-only if it's so
useful, after all?
Here's the thing about the risk
involved. It's asymmetric. The downside
of a read-only error is zero. I just
ignore it.
The downside of a write error is
unbounded.
And personal AI operates in the
high-stakes environment. Your
relationships, your career, your
reputation.
I'd rather miss out on automated emails
than have a misfire nuke my life.
But there's also a subtler philosophical
argument, almost a matter of taste.
Read-only isn't just safer, it produces
better analysis. The moment your AI
writes to your data sources, the exhaust
fumes are contaminated. You're no longer
observing your cognition. You're
observing a human-AI hybrid, and you
can't tell which patterns are yours.
Sure, the observer changes your
behavior, too, but the feedback loop is
mediated by you, not automated.
You read the reflection. You decide what
to do. That's a different thing from the
AI writing your draft.
And there's an argument to be made that
you don't want the AI to write your
draft in the first place, that you
should reclaim your agency.
Might be a hard sell for this crowd, I
think, but worth considering.
At this point, you might be asking, "Why
not throw all this into open Claude on a
read-only mount?"
Which I have.
Here's the thing.
The producer The observer produces more
value per interaction by a wide margin.
The agent saves me 30 seconds on a
weather check.
The observer shows me I've been avoiding
my most important project for 2 weeks.
Not to mention that there's less risk of
exfiltration and cognitive pollution.
The argument I'm making here is that
read-only isn't a stepping stone to
\
real agents. It helps you do things
well, yes, but it fits a different gap,
serves a different need.
It's a different product category.
The industry frames read-only as a
limitation you graduate from.
I think that's wrong.
Observers and agents are different
tools, and mayor isn't a broken butler.
So, that's the value proposition.
But I'd be doing you a disservice if I
stopped here.
Let's put on the paranoid hat.
What keeps me up at night?
Let's start with the mosaic effect.
There's something called the mosaic
effect, where you put together a lot of
small pieces of information and you get
a picture.
My own slide copy describes the security
risk perfectly.
The same cross-referencing that makes
the system useful makes it a devastating
target.
So, careful there.
The other side of the coin, Simon
Willison's lethal triquetra.
In case you don't know the lethal
triquetra, it's a security risk model
that combines three factors: private
data, untrusted content, and external
communications.
I initially thought we only broke the
lethal triquetra, and it doesn't, not
fully. It removes the natural
exfiltration circle channels, but the
third leg is any ability to communicate
externally,
and shell access still has that.
In short, the system isn't fireproof,
and I'm not claiming that. Even in the
best-case scenario, I'm still sending
data to Anthropic
on a network that's mostly open,
with a lot more information lying around
that is strictly speaking required.
I'm not claiming the system is secure.
I'm claiming that I've thought about
where it isn't, and I've decided which
risks I'm willing to carry.
It's different from not knowing.
The worst security posture is the one
you haven't examined.
With that said, I still think there's
something worthwhile to be learned from
all this.
Your digital exhaust is the most
underused data set you own.
Reflect on it and use it to make
yourself better.
Thanks for listening.